[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm Linc and
I'm Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is comedian
vlogger and full time co-host of the
youtube series SourceFed Steve Zaragoza
ha ha
you know SourceFed you've heard of
SourceFed most one of the most popular
current event shows on the Internet
over a million a have subscribers on
their main channel and Steve has been
hosting it for three years and he's
really helped shape what it has become
oh yeah you can also find Steve
co-hosting SourceFed nerd another very
popular channel within the SourceFed
stable as well as on the new SourceFed
podcast so check that out he's great
host and we've always thought that Steve
was a really funny guy he certainly is
and you know now we call him a friend
too so you know when you have a in your
biscuit we were friends but you know
it's like taking the relationship to
another level when when you add some
like microphones and us having this this
conversation phones and headphones -
does it yeah we're super funny guy but
we did get to talk through the serious
side of Steve a little bit so you'll
hear that we talked about growing up in
a sketchy neighborhood with drive-by
shootings in a halfway house next door
his job as a video game tester which may
not be what you think it is going to be
if you're if you're looking to get into
that profession how he caught his first
break and the interesting risk he took
to capitalize on it and what that first
audition for SourceFed looked like we
also talked about one of the more
serious subjects that we've talked about
on is the divorce that Steve is going
through with his his wife separated now
in the in the midst of a divorce what
led up to that and how he's handled that
how that has changed him and how he's
still in the midst of dealing with that
he calls it one of the most difficult
things he's ever had to do so Steve
opened up was very open and talking
about that so stick around for that but
first guys we just want to remind you to
download our new live album song
biscuits Volume one I'm calling it live
because I mean it was a recorded live
there was no audience except for I mean
the cameras that then we put it out
there for you guys on the good my guest
Channel in one sense though link that
makes everything live right I mean yeah
everything was live at some point okay
every song but you can call it a live
album because that implies things that
it's not but you should download it
anyway on iTunes so miss gets volume one
yeah all these songs recorded in about
an hour using your suggestions that you
gave us on the internet usually
collaborating with somebody here's an
example of one of those the five nights
at Freddy's song featuring markiplier
[Music]
responsible if markiplier wasn't there
we wouldn't have known any too much
about nothing he was like an a
collaborator and and an expert what's it
called consultant
yeah consultant fifteen original songs
all based on your tweets masterfully
crafted and available to put into your
ears holes your ears holes there's two
ears and right so get that on itunes
also available on Amazon thanks for
giving those things for reading and
reviewing the album on iTunes
yes and now on to the biscuit do you
remember the first time we met Steve as
you met us at the same time so was it
was it the the what was that [ __ ] was
that the thing of the paramount launch
we were standing in line for like ice
cream right it was a food car it was
right it was an ice cream food it was
like ice cream sandwiches or something
after the screen something we all came
up and or was it tacos it could have
been talking they were both I think we
had both man yeah we did have bro
you know it was a dinner and dessert but
we were in line and you got in line but
I remember the biggest thing I remember
that night besides meeting you yes we
showed up and we were over dressed like
retina had on ties and oh yeah I guess
looked great but you also weren't
dressed similarly I did it I didn't nice
up a little bit yeah cuz I didn't know
but it was one yeah I didn't know either
and they called it a premiere yeah and
everyone else just like came from work
or whatever they were doing that super -
casual and so here we are in ties what's
worse
what's worse really being overdressed or
underdressed I guess it depends on what
kind of person you are because I like to
doubt well for me I'm a
wacky guy so if I'm overdressed I'm
loving it going sidenote
only a wacky guy and refer to himself as
a wacky guy I think that is the
definition of being a wacky guy is being
able to use the word whacking searly I
had no idea what conclusion you were
gonna come to until you said it cuz
you're like I'm a wacky guy so that
means I like to be underdressed either
way no I would have thought that wacky
people like to under dress because look
oh yeah he shouldn't be here because
he's underdressed but he's wacky is that
guy from the streets
no no just wacky right but I feel like
couldn't you say the exact same thing
about an overdressed person I mean guys
gotta be wacky something's wrong with
that guy yeah like that what wacky means
something's wrong it could be wacky
could be either this man is so silly he
doesn't know any better
yeah or like Ray's right crazy like a
man who dresses up in a three-piece suit
to like mumble to himself on a mortgage
yes which is a thing it's totally you
know why I got dressed welcome but I
would have it but I think someone who's
overdressed is you know the risk is all
that stiffs trying too hard well yeah
he's got something to prove those two
guys who showed up together make
Internet videos and aren't as good as
this series we're trying to prove them
to compensate yeah well did you guys
feel super awkward after that like did
you realize right away that you were
overdressed yeah there's a little bit
you know there's a little bit of
built-in insecurity when anybody from
our world kind of goes into even though
that was like a on a lot of Netflix show
but it was on a lot yeah and it was
movie stars it was movie yeah you're
like oh yeah we're my guy from YouTube
and nobody knows and yeah we're a duo
and we're both dressed and ties you know
should we get tacos or should we just
leave but I think that we you know we we
recognize your face we knew you from
SourceFed yeah and you know we go way
back with Joe and you know so that's but
that's when we met you know we started
talking and we over some food
I scream yeah it was great but you were
also overdressed so it was I was that
was the tipping point it was like what
am I gonna speak to Steve is this gonna
be the first meeting
he's overdressed absolutely this is the
moment we're all in the same place
you're thinking exactly the same we were
yeah do you think that there's some sort
of chip on our shoulders and I'm talking
about all three of us here you know when
you enter like a some more of a
traditional entertainment environment I
mean is there something to that that's
like I don't feel like we had anything
to prove but maybe we did I mean I
wanted to be underdressed versus
overdressed
do you do you feel like there's
something there like when you say when
people ask you what you do and it's like
well you know I'm on a youtube show and
I'm you know how does it feel I don't
know I feel like I feel like for me back
then it was like I was I was still kind
of just getting into the SourceFed thing
so it was kind of like this was like 2
or 3 years ago right yeah two and a half
years ago maybe yeah yeah at least two
yeah yeah cuz we were with Stevie and it
was like the first thing we had gone to
with Steve Ian but in that year yeah I'm
just saying in general though there is a
sense of even even now when you're
having conversations with someone who
like has a point of reference for
entertainment or is in traditional
entertainment there's this like I mean
we're still looked at kind of a separate
thing why what do you say when somebody
asks you what you do oh man it changes
because sometimes they'll just say like
just to keep it simple and to not have
to like explain and explain and explain
sometimes they'll just be like I'm an
actor hmm you're just straight up say
I'm an actor right and then when they go
like Oh what do you do or like what have
I ever seen you in anything then it's
like okay well I do YouTube stuff like I
do mostly YouTube stuff okay so that's
not really acting is it well I mean if
you're still there again you tried to
get out of and try to make you suck you
in for the long explanation and now you
seem like a liar too but sometimes it's
easier to lie than to like explain what
is what it is we do yeah like I went
into we went to a sushi restaurant with
our families last night but Rhett wasn't
coming in yet and it was a family right
there at the first table and the kid he
was probably 10 years old like he
you know he was like link I was like hey
man and his dad looked at me like you
know this man coming into the sushi run
met him at the park he's on a bench by
himself
mumbling three-piece suit over dress and
I say to the dead yes I'm a food critic
and I'm here to review the restaurant I
have a I have a popular internet
presence as it and I still backed into
internet presence but I was I was kind
of messing with him to see if his saw it
what his son would do was his son
laughing his son was totally confused
maybe you made him think oh man maybe I
got the wrong guy maybe a food critic
but there's a I mean it's getting better
I mean people understand you tubers a
lot more but well the thing that I way
that always happens I feel like it's
because saying I'm a youtuber can mean
you know what I do this other thing and
I also do youtuber could be like no I've
done this for a long time and it's we
make a living and we run a company and
but you don't want to say those things
using like a jerk when you try to
justify it right it's like it's like
wearing a tie oh you're youtuber so is
that going well and I'm like it's going
pretty well
it's but yeah yeah let me tell you many
people watch my slip and you pull out
your analytics did you just put you in a
difficult situation but I I think that
yeah so going back to the the genesis of
this whole thing
yeah I'm gladly admit I've got a chip on
my shoulder yeah that's part of it I
mean that's that's why we keep pushing
right it is you kind of have to right
yeah especially in this kind of business
in the hoenn the whole YouTube thing
right I think so I'm trying I mean we're
not releasing an album actually we did
just release but so you said you were
gonna do working on now you asked us
about our album yeah but well tell us
about that you're doing an album I am
you promised the Internet in like
November of 14 yeah I made it I made a
very interesting promise that I would
release now them and there's no reason
for me not to but what was that was that
an impromptu promise oh no no so it's I
I don't know I've been doing music stuff
for a while and on the on the SourceFed
show I've done like some songs and stuff
oh you guys talked about the bear the
bear song yeah we were we were
rewatching the bear song which was just
totally off the coast it was an improv
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely ridiculous so just something
about the Trisha being there in like
yeah clapping and smiling all the right
places
yeah Trisha like was down for everything
she's totally down like you started
going to the weirdest place possible
some people would be like that's weird
and kind of shut it down that's whack
but yeah that's too wacky
but Trisha would be like yeah I'm gonna
clap along and smile and go right along
with it I don't think it would have
worked as well if it was somebody else
but yeah no I have been doing music for
a while on SourceFed and so whenever I
mean people are like I get tweets often
that are like when you're gonna do an
album when you're gonna do album when
you gonna release real songs when's the
bear song gonna be on iTunes stuff like
that yeah and Lee and I actually used to
sing a lot too together and then people
would be like one are you and Lee gonna
make an album and where's this and so
I've always talked about doing it and
I've always wanted to do it and now I
just feel like why not it's it's kind of
I mean it's kind of easy to make an
album now oh yeah you can make one at
home you don't need like a studio to do
it sometimes where you had the process
because you made the promise and I did
make the product months ago I did I'm
actually believing
five songs deep oh yeah I don't have
complete lyrics does anybody have them I
don't know yeah I don't want an EP by
the way inside so no it's EEP I'm five
songs deep and that's the that's the
name of the album five songs deep is the
bear song one of them I don't know if I
don't know yet because I don't know if I
own the bear song
what do you because it might be the
worst bad thing oh you gotta figure that
so I need to figure that out you know a
good way to figure it out how do you do
that put it on yeah but I'm still on
SourceFed just call it right var song
change the words a little bit and I
meant to say e to because that would be
the bar so I'm gonna be a re song the
VAR e the bear song yeah you're naked I
like that it's definitely so what are
the five can you tell us this is what I
know about the album this is what I can
tell you it's an ant it's definitely
about animals know about animals it's
not a bear see that's the thing everyone
because it's an animals thing and the
reason why let me tell you let me back
up a little bit please let's go back to
the genesis of this a little bit so
people have been asking for it and so I
started really thinking about it about
making an album and I've done like songs
in the past and I've got like some weird
stuff that like in fact I started a band
out of high school called Christmas
surprise with a friend of mine and it's
just this really strange I played this
foreign guy did a seasonal band it no it
wasn't it was year round
it was a year round Christmas as wacky
because it was exactly imagine a
Christmas surprise in July it's a real
surprise doesn't get any more surprising
than that so it was it was very like
folk music E and we did a lot of like I
did a dinosaur song and so I have this
song called dinosaur land that I'm very
proud of that just kind of it's on my
soundcloud and that's it
maybe just take my hand watch yourself
the forest is dangerous
[Music]
baby the creatures are ravenous
in this land
that's far from home
[Music]
it is a land
we're creatures were
how many people on earth ever have said
I've got this song dinosaur land that
I'm really proud like that's the great
thing about you Steve again it's like
that moment of like you're so funny all
the time yeah and even the things when
you're just like being straight with me
is hilarious so you've got this dinosaur
land song that you're really proud of
I'm very proud of his dinosaur song that
I wrote with a friend of mine named
Isaiah and so that it's just sitting
there and then like you know years and
years and years and years later when I
started doing SourceFed a good friend of
mine who's actually a producer at
SourceFed now Darren Gardner yeah he you
guys know Darren Aaron's a good guy he
came to me after trip from New York and
said I went to this Museum in New York
and I saw this massive whale this like
whale statue or something
and he's like I thought of a funny vine
where like someone where like you asked
someone excuse me where are the wealth
and you just yell out whales to
someone's face and he's like it's just
as my and I thought it was funny and I
was like why don't we make it into a
song and so we started writing this
whales song and so now we have this
whales song and then I've also got this
dinosaur song and everybody and a lot of
people really like the whales song so
then I was thinking and then they start
saying like we'll make an album make an
album and it sounds like okay I've got
this dinosaur song I've got this whale
song I've got a bear song yeah I mean
just complete the - circle of life I'm
kind of there I'm already there so it's
gonna be a subtle doubt the ecosystem
building out build on that world
bringing that universe in there
and so I've so yeah it's any it's gonna
be an album about animals and right now
I've got a song called
so got whales which is like them I think
that the single and then we've got I've
got the Dinosaur Land song and then I'm
working on a song I've never taught I
haven't talked about this this is
exclusive for you guys sexually three
people are very excited about hearing
this right now I'm feeling they're
excited they're yes so am i it's buzzing
on my phone there's a song about the
axolotl you guys know what the axe Alana
list
no that's the body part
no it's not a body part I might take an
outlet you don't need visionary blender
no the the axolotl is a some people say
is like the real-life Pokemon character
it's like this little sea creature that
looks you've seen it it's got like a big
smile on its face and it looks like
horrible anyway they're going extinct
and they're and I believe they don't
exist in the wild anymore so now they're
just in captivity but they're adorable
creatures and so I have a song called
the axolotl lullaby which is which is
sounds that kind of it is a shammy like
you're putting it to sleep to like die
you don't like to go extinct you know I
think it's one of those things where
it'll be open to interpretation but it's
definitely a lullaby like go to sleep
but in my mind I think it is like an
extinction song goodbye sleeps are they
all kind of improv based or you go more
in like a meticulous joke direction like
what do you know what do we have to
expect here I think it will the whale
song it's all absurd stuff it's like
very I don't know I'd liked I'd like it
to be slightly molest
just kind of like impromptu improv
comedy more like slightly
well-thought-out but I don't know if
that works for this type of music I feel
like it needs to feel still impromptu
because people have the bear song a lot
and then they like the whale song and so
it should be pretty like a pretty live
performance yeah I feel like it I feel
like people would like that yeah I would
like it I don't want to do it for you
yeah but for me I'll commit to listening
really we commit to listening to at
least buy a copy we'll share him at
least five songs deep into you those
five songs are gonna be the best because
that's where most most of the time will
be play yeah first five ok well let's
find out how Steve Zaragoza became the
Steve we see before us right now uh were
you from I'm from Oxnard oh really
yeah that's a street it is a string it
takes you all the way to Oxnard take
seats you are so it's almost like like
Oz yeah Oxnard like is the street that
goes down the valley yeah well one of
them yeah yeah no there is this big main
Oxnard Street that goes through the
value but there's
also a city called ox now that's like
where the there's some boats there there
are boats where you get in the ocean and
on your sailboat yeah Port Hueneme
yeah is a little port in Oxnard where
you can park your boats there's also
like the Seabees which are these
military guys that have like a little
base there a little base set up so
that's where you were born and raised
born raised in Oxnard what was this
situation like both parents siblings
yeah I got to I got a mom and dad and an
older brother named Frank he's a good
guy
he and I are pretty close he has a child
now you're an uncle I'm an uncle it's
weird
is he in the nard still he's in
Camarillo now that come out here
supposedly the best climate on earth I
don't I don't disagree sort of been told
it's possible that in like Santa Barbara
Santa Barbara is a nice yeah that's town
that's gonna be good weather there so
what what was the vibe like there what'd
your parents do what was your upbringing
like Oxnard is a very dangerous town
especially when I was a kid a lot of
gang activity oh really injure yeah a
lot of shootings and gangs doing
terrible things like at one point in my
neighborhood there was like a drive-by
shooting at the end of my block my dad's
car got like bullet holes in the glass
not the sticker kind that you get it
like not the actual real like potential
death bullet holes Wow
so were you on the on the fringe of
something dangerous or was your
neighborhood very much dangerous I think
my neighborhood wasn't as dangerous as
some other parts of Oxnard but it was
very much like a ghetto in a way like
next door right in the entire time I
grew up next door there was a halfway
house and was full of like rehabilitated
adults so it could be like recovering
drug addicts and also like potential
like criminals like hard criminals that
are being rehabilitated and brought back
into society in the end what's your
interface with these people well they
live right next door so we would they
would talk to us over the fence
sometimes as children which is kind of
telling it's just talking there was
never any like physical interaction
there was a lot of weird activity there
a lot in fact more than once the police
needed to enter our home to get into our
back
- to stop an altercation in the house
next door in the halfway house did you
know that this was kind of a big deal
for a kid no I didn't because you're
normal it just seems so normal to me
because I grew up with it you know like
and also something that like my friends
still talk about to this day is that we
had bars on our windows like that you
know like the kind of like paranoid like
we don't want anyone in our home to bars
but it wasn't like a paranoid reason it
was because it's literally a dangerous
neighborhood that people like break into
homes yeah type deal so that was like my
parents just didn't put them in your
bedroom which is weird
they must have wanted me to be
protective no they it was on all the
bars would your your parents do my dad
worked in like machine like he built
hard drive parts so he worked in this
like factory where they built like the
tiny pieces that used to go into old
school hard drives and my mom was a
teacher she teach like preschool and
kindergarten and stuff like that and did
they teach you to be so comedic how did
that dr. Budd you know I don't know
because neither my parents are
intentionally funny they're like the
kind of like it's one of those things
were like and you know what I'm talking
about were like cuz my dad is my dad
grew up in Mexico until he was like 18
and then he moved to the US okay so he's
got this very much like foreign kind of
like mentality so he's got this kind of
like strange outlook on life and and how
to be a person and a man and kind of
like all the machismo stuff which is the
exact opposite of what I am because I'm
the most like I'm the girliest not
Mexican dude ever and what both my
parents are Mexican I'm a Mexican guy so
what what do you think contributed to
you saying okay well I'm the I'm the
complete opposite in a lot of ways like
you know how did that come about I think
I was just a super weird kid and I would
do very weird things and I was always
like my dad had his Betamax camera and
in Betamax is like the stuff before VHS
and my brother and I would borrow it and
film all these sketches and why did why
did he have him what did he use it for
you
you're shining the light what was he
doing on July 4th 1980 Betamax yeah now
we're getting somewhere
no I think he was interested in filming
like doing family kind of like home
video home videos like like videos of my
brother and I growing up going to the
beach and like hanging and going camping
with the family and stuff like okay you
know it's normal dad video type stuff
sure so we would take the camera and my
brother and I would make these sketches
and we'd have like puppets we'd have
like Sesame Street puppets and Kermit
and stuff when we do like the Muppet
Show type sketches and stuff like that
so we were always my brother and I were
both very wacky dudes there's that word
again
and so and I think it started to realize
that it was a little bit weirder than
like my brother at times and then very
much different and weirder and had a
different sense of humor than my mom and
dad or like my cousins or even some of
my friends so I started to realize like
I guess I'm kind of a wacky guy and I
make people laugh so I guess this is
like kind of my thing and my mom was
like super supportive of it too like she
would watch me like draw weird things
like I draw comic book type things and I
would like do sketches and put on little
like talent shows in the house and my
mom was like super supportive of it so I
feel like it was entertain you you were
very much an entertainer yeah from the
very start
yeah so like I mean there's lots of
people who are successful on YouTube
that though they will have grabbed their
parents camera and but it's more of like
oh I want to be a filmmaker right versus
this is just one of many mediums it
could be it could be it could be
charcoal it could be a Betamax camera
I'm an entertainer and it's just got to
happen that sounds like your story yeah
wasn't it I had zero interest in the
filmmaking aspect of it I had more
interest in being in front of the camera
and like making people laugh and doing
wacky things like a talent show in grade
school you know you were up there doing
your wacko did it did this did you stand
out not only from your family but in
terms of your community cuz you said
your mom and dad are both Mexican so are
you in a Mexican community yeah for the
most part that primary
primarily a Hispanic area of town yes so
and also growing up - you kind of had
the pressures of like oh man are you
gonna be like a homie gonna be like
you're gonna join a gang are you gonna
do that kind of thing like the climate
was very straight how does that is that
like the quintessential like a kid you
know like how does that happen I don't
know I feel like it's one of those
things where like depending on what
school you go to it's kind of like what
kind of clique you're gonna blend into
and then who you're gonna associate with
and who your friends are gonna be and I
feel like for me it could have ended up
really badly where I wouldn't be able to
associate with anybody but luckily I was
able to kind of like find other
jokesters and kind of like entertainers
and class clown type people and
associate with them and steer clear of
the kind of more dangerous lifestyle
like as a kid I did nothing dangerous I
never like started garage fires or you
know got arrested or tried to steal
candy or like rode my bike and like in
the middle of the street or anything
like that I was this super like did you
experience any sort of criticism because
you because you made those choices
because you didn't want to hang out yeah
I was I was definitely pushed around a
lot in bullied for not being like like
how come you don't wanna play soccer man
or how come you don't wanna play
football or you know why don't you want
to be all sporty and my brother would
even be like let's play basketball I'd
be like I kind of want to just play
Battletoads like bubble bobble or
something it starts with the B does that
count so how did you start to find your
breakthrough it's like you know what was
it a high school play was it you know
where was your where was that outlet for
you that this this is really starting to
take off I think it was kind of like I
would always gravitate towards the the
entertainment stuff so even as early as
like third and fourth grade I would do
like little talent showcase type things
or like whenever there was a talent show
get my friends together and we'd get a
song and we'd like you know lip-sync to
a song or something like that so I knew
I guess I always knew that I wanted to
entertain in some aspect as like a
younger kid but definitely as I got into
high school I would try to do plays and
musicals and things like that like I did
our town
did like Bye Bye Birdie and like little
bit things here and there but my big
break
quote-unquote was when I was Seymour in
Little Shop of Horrors Oh high school
and that was like a dream come true it
was like is that a plant
oh yeah well no Seymour is the lead the
main guy the lizard Moretti
yeah that's the Rick Moranis that is the
dude he's like the lead role in that so
I was like super stoked I was like this
is me this is the role I was born to
play my mom would like you will let me
watch Little Shop of Horrors as a very
young kid which maybe she shouldn't have
done but like but it helped you right it
totally helped me it definitely like I
loved the creatures and kind of like the
comedy and like you know I loved it even
before I even understood a lot of the
jokes and a lot of the the stuff going
on in the movie but no did you kill it I
killed it in the auditions first of all
and then I killed it in the rehearsals
and then we got to like this halfway
point where we were like halfway through
rehearsals you know everyone's all
selected we got our understudies
everything's ready to go but my drama
teacher came to me and said listen um
your grades suck like your grades are
real bad like and if you don't pick them
up and if you don't like maintain at
least this amount which was like
something ridiculous like if you don't
at least get a d-plus in like your
classes we can't let you do this and so
I was like oh crap
ah I don't know what to do and so it it
was weird because Azadi right but I mean
like I it's it seems weird to think
about it now as an adult but like and
you hear people say it too like I was
too cool for school or something but I
just feel like I wasn't meant to be in
school like school just never worked for
me it just was never a place where I
felt welcome or comfortable or you know
math class and English class and things
like that like I just couldn't focus I
wanted to like make the class laugh or
like draw pictures or do something
creative so what did you do I just did
that I made the class laughs and I but I
mean ultimatum I mean I honestly lost it
I lost the role and I was kicked out of
the play yeah yeah and it was this huge
like
turning point in my life where I was
like oh man like I really screwed this
up a lot of people were counting on me a
lot of people wanted me to do this and I
just kind of like let it go
because I wasn't going to like put the
initiative into like really like land
this but you didn't let it slow you down
I didn't let it slow me down but it
really it I kind of spiraled into this
like I don't care kind of like teen
angsty type place where I was just like
you know screw this and screw that and
like school wasn't for me so I stopped
going and I would just go to like my
video production class and I would go to
my drama class and that was it and then
I would skip out of everything else and
I wasn't doing I wasn't like going to
the mall or like going you know behind
the bushes to smoke pot or like hang out
with my bad kid friends or whatever I
just would like become this super
anxiety ridden depressed antisocial kind
of hermit person because I went into
this weird failure territory of like I
sucked at school I couldn't do this
thing I couldn't do that I was bad at
this and I'm a weirdo that doesn't feel
like I belong so like I just went into
this weird like hermit crabs zone and I
know you you've you've been really open
about your your past struggles with
weight yes and was that beginning to be
a struggle Elliott high school yeah I
mean I was always just the kind of like
cuddly fat kid that was like a nerd but
he was funny and like you know I was in
the friend zone if you want to call it
that or whatever and I would just be
very much in this kind of like class
clowny place but definitely not in this
kind of like comfortable like I feel
good about being a teenager place so I
didn't really get to like enjoy being a
teenager because at all these
insecurities and I had all this anxiety
which I didn't know at the time was
anxiety or depression or whatever it was
and then to top it all off all I wanted
to do was like entertain and make people
laugh and make music and sketches and do
comedy and I didn't realize at the time
that like if I wanted to do that what I
needed to do was work my ass off and
like really get in there and study and
do all that like everybody else did even
the comedians that I idolized and I
guess I just didn't see that at the time
so it sounds like you were kind of on
that that was kind of a you were on a
downward trend
how far down did it go before you found
a way back up I think it I think
honestly it was that I met the girl that
would eventually become my wife that is
now not my wife that is now my ex-wife
but I mean I met this girl who like
changed my life in high school in high
school yeah and so it was one of those
things where she was like and she was
like an a straight-a student like she
her grade point average was like insane
her parents were like wait a minute
you're gonna be dating this guy who's
like a total loser and like it was one
of those situations yeah and I feel like
we met her same time we met you yeah you
did yeah Sara Sara yeah yeah so Sara
like basically pulled me out of this
funk of like I I'm a loser and I'm a
failure and she kind of like taught me
about how you know I can succeed if I
just work and I can do whatever I want
to do and I should like get out there
and get a job and get my license and so
she really kind of like whipped me into
shape so if it wasn't for her I don't
know where the hell I'd be it'd probably
be this like weird 30 year old man
living at home still and were you dating
or was that friendzone
I wasn't date well Sara and I were very
good friends for like a year and then we
ended up dating and then my life like
completely turned around and that was
one like everything went on the
up-and-up okay so this is like right
after high school this was like just
before I dropped out of high school so
it was like junior year senior year of
high school but you did drop out I
dropped it yeah yep and then what so
what I did was I did a bunch of stupid
retail jobs like I worked at like Hot
Topic in the mall which is like the dumb
it was a terrible job
what a whack t-shirt a lot of black
t-shirts lost Sponge Bob and black
t-shirts which was weird combination
that yeah accents defy two sections this
way exactly you're in the front you're
like I'm bringing my kids in and all of
a sudden I'll keep going back here kids
yeah yeah I hate my dad section and this
is the isle of Spongebob and a little
pony section
it's very strange the bipolar store but
I worked at a bunch of retail jobs and I
worked at like a videogame store and
then I got married in 2006
and at the time I had this really
terrible job I was doing like Quality
Assurance QA testing at a video game
company called THQ and THQ made like
some of the worst games like really
difficult video games and you're playing
them to see if they work yeah it was
worse I mean these jobs exist for a
reason and I'm glad they do because they
make video games even better but a lot
of these kids these like out of high
school sometimes still in a high school
college student kids are just like
sitting like brainless zombies in front
of a computer monitor playing these
games over and over again and you have
to play them incorrectly you can't even
really play them because it sounds like
a cool job like oh man I get to play
video games all day but what they don't
tell you is is you're playing them wrong
all day so like you're racing your car
backwards on the track you're like
jumping down this same hole nine hundred
to see if like that accidentally beats
the game silly beats the game or if it
makes like Mario's head pop off Mario it
was bad game it was really bad it was
like some kind of rocket power
you guys remember the show rocket power
this might have been beyond our time
like it was we were older when that was
good but yeah you would something would
go wrong and you'd have to take note
yeah and you'd have to I mean and you
had to like make the most thorough
ridiculous notes it would just be like
you couldn't just say guy falls and his
leg stays in place in this world you had
to be like at this specific point in the
game these are the enemies nearby it was
like the most torturous gross job ever
talking about sucking the fun out of
supposed to be exactly makes you hate
video the sacrificial lamb a video so
you can enjoy it
exactly so you come home to Sarah like
yeah you're like newlyweds you're coming
you're coming home from this terrible
job hating everything and just thinking
like what am I gonna do like this is
gonna be my life now like no this time
we at this point we'd moved to Oak Park
which is kind of like in Thousand Oaks
ish ty berry and this was like in 2006
and so I would come home and be like I
hate my job I want to entertain and at
the same time I'm with my friends making
sketches
and not necessarily doing stuff on
YouTube yet but knowing about YouTube
and having that be kind of like an
inspiration for a lot of the sketcher
and you're slowly getting closer to Los
Angeles slowly getting closer to Los
Angeles little by little and so one day
there was this contest at Sony Pictures
to be there like official vlogger or
blogger for comic-con
they had like comic-con coming up and
they were like we want someone to be our
official Sony Pictures blogger and so
the contest was to make a video
explaining why you would want to do that
in why you would be good for that make a
video why you would want to type about
so strange yeah be a blogger and just
write things but make a video explaining
why you'd be good at it so weird but my
buddy Owen and I we put our heads
together and we I made this little video
and it's still up on the internet and
it's just like why I should be their
their spokesperson and I did this stupid
joke that was like at the time Brooke
Burke was like this huge news person
like and she would go around and do her
wild on showing me and so I said I'm not
Brooke Burke but I can be and I slapped
this nametag on my shirt this is Brooke
Burke on it and it was just like
whatever it was just stupid and the next
thing I know Sony calls me and they're
like you won we want you to come to
comic-con all-expenses-paid will get you
a hotel and everything and we want you
to write for us and I was like this is
great this is the big break this was the
thing I was waiting for so I got the
call literally while I was at THQ on the
job and it was like middle of the day
you were jumping into the 17th hole and
it was just a nightmare world that I was
in 17th time you kill yourself and so I
got the call I went outside found out I
won the contest I came back into THQ God
all my stuff didn't say a word and just
walk right out the door and drove home
it's like a movie yeah it was seriously
like a movie I didn't call them I didn't
tell them I didn't put in my two-weeks
or anything I was just like I knew this
was it I wonder how many days they
thought you were like a ghost you
actually went down the hole yes
the game somebody to make that no so I
left and then I got home and I told
Sarah I was like I won this contest this
is it and she was like yeah but what
about your job
forget it don't even worry about it and
she was like so pissed off of me she was
like you need stability and she was I
mean god bless her she like tried to
keep me as on the level as possible it's
a reasonable question because comic-con
was I thinking honestly if it's like
thinking about it now what was I
thinking how could this contest be my
big break but somehow I felt in the pit
of my stomach that this was it like I I
knew I had like the the the charisma I
knew I could do it I know I could
somehow weasel my way into something
like just using my attitude and my
energy and my positivity and just
throwing it all out there in the world
and just giving it everything so I went
and did this and I convinced Sarah that
everything was gonna be okay and like I
said I mean we had just gotten married
just moved into an apartment in Oak Park
I mean Sarah was like thinking about
real life logical stuff and I was
thinking of like dream in the clouds
this is like a big chance I'm taking
type stuff so we did it and you cut the
safety net I totally cut the safety net
which from an entertainment standpoint I
mean we fast for we kind of know where
you've landed and you know it I you know
I'm very interested in connecting the
dots and I want to but I will say that
it there's a I've heard many people who
make it entertainment say at some point
you just have to go for it and if
they're and I've heard a lot of people
say you what you can't have a plan B you
know even though it makes total sense
the interesting thing was you cut your
safety net for two people and that's you
know that's it has to be scary
oh it's insane but I mean imagine having
a family or imagine having like so many
other people counting on you to bring in
a steady amount of income I know the
feeling like we're I mean how could you
how could you make such a big like weird
chance or how could you take a big
chance like that it was easier for us
because I mean we we inched into it much
more slowly in the move to LA move
across
tree was in answer to the opportunity to
have our own television show so it
wasn't like it wasn't as big of a risk
for us I will say right but then what
happened after you went to comic-con you
killed it so I killed it and and my wife
was at the time was like talking me up
and so the next thing I know I get a
call and they're like we want you to
come to the Sony Pictures studio a lot
and we'll do it we'll take you around on
the back lot tour so you can check out
everything and then we'll have you come
into our digital division where where
they like work with you at comic-con and
we'll have you interview and maybe get a
job
you're like see right old you I know and
I was like this is it this is what I was
thinking what happened and it just so
happened it happened and so I go there
and I take the tour and Sarah's with me
and then the next thing I know I'm in
someone's office they're interviewing me
and then they're like can you start
Monday and I'm like yes I can why yes I
can
that that like freefall going from one
trapeze you cut the net I'm yeah the
analogy going but going I like you like
you let go of my yeah it wasn't long
before you caught the next one so it
wasn't at all like I quit my job a week
ago and then there I am getting a new
job at Sony Pictures at their digital
division and but they threw me big they
hired me on his talent for their like to
throw at events and stuff to be like a
blogger type person but then the next
thing I know I'm working in their video
production world and then five years
later I'm like a sound design guy doing
the sounds if you go to the original
paul blart mall cop website every sound
you hear was me i did almost least
mostly farts all fart sounds yeah I got
that first part son he made literally
scared me like oh you should have hired
me back this where were you when I
needed a real good part
[Laughter]
for that website still I'm sure it is
because there's a sequel okay
how did that happen I don't know man
because I didn't drop that high school
didn't go to college had zero like I
have no resume at this point it's like I
worked at a video game store and that's
that and so for some reason I just kind
of weaseled my way into this but did you
feel your job did you feel like I mean
where I thought you might be going with
that was I started doing this but then I
ended up making sounds on a website and
that wasn't me that wasn't what I wanted
wasn't it definitely wasn't it was just
this kind of like natural organic
progression in this corporate world of
me trying everything I could to stay
relevant and not be fired because the
guy sitting next to me went to USC film
school and graduated like with like
crazy honors in his class and the guy on
my right went to brown and graduated in
marketing and there's all these like
crazy people with like accolades and
awards and Greg and like crazy framed
graduation diploma things and and on and
Here I am the like the loser guy that
somehow just weaseled his way in and and
I honestly feel like at this point that
kept me around basically just for morale
because I'd walk around making people
laugh and kept the positivity up and
like right was like just that guy that
they're like oh man you just make us
laugh and it's so funny and I was
entertaining all these people and it was
nice but it wasn't fulfilling me in any
way creatively it was so that's what was
the next turn out of desk work so I'm
I'm at this point where I start joining
like la casting and I and I try to get
an agent and I'm trying to do you know
extra work and like I was I did like I
was in a Buckcherry music video I was in
a Buckcherry music video we've met
Buckcherry
on the red carpet yeah well I filmed you
there it is that's the six degrees of
Kevin Bacon with red limbs were you like
a you like a lead in this man I was I
was the funny guy in the video it was
the funny guy in the video and it was
the video is called too drunk to it and
that's where the call
and so I look it up you can sometimes
you are actually already have it up here
anyway so I did that and I did stuff I
did like a thousand ways to die an
episode of 1000 ways to die and then I
did like some little things here and
there but it still wasn't enough and
then one day I sent in and a tape
- James Hafner who works at with Philip
DeFranco at Bank or whatever and then
they were like the next thing I know the
casting call for what became swords fit
it was a casting call for in fact this
is this is a weird bit of trivia it was
a casting call for what would end up
being curb cash which was the show that
Kevin brew ik ended up doing which was
killed almost immediately but they
wanted a man on the street like a funny
man on the street type guy and so I came
in and did an audition and then the next
thing I know I'm at an audition space
and likely Newton's there and joe bereta
is there and Elliott Morgan's there and
then all these other people that like I
would meet later on that ended up being
also YouTube people and then they're
doing like chemistry tests and then
they're like we want you we want you to
come work at SourceFed we want you to be
the fourth person we want it to be Joe
Elliott Lee Steve and this was like just
before SourceFed started so it was like
I would love to do that but I'm working
at a job where I have like a 401k and I
have like benefits and vacation time and
like a decent salary and then this is
like a YouTube thing that is just
starting yeah and I didn't know yeah
anything that you didn't have a point of
reference for Philip DeFranco zero I
didn't even know who he was yeah I never
heard his name before right and so I
didn't know all I knew is is that this
was this would be an entertainer job
that I could get hired for where I would
be making funny videos every day so he
turned it down well I I did initially I
was like I can do part-time and so they
were like okay let's do part-time so I
would like I was able to maintain that
for awhile I would come in and do a
little bit now those were my first
appearances on SourceFed it's
interesting that without that point of
reference you know you you said well I
got a 401k it's like even in your mind
over those five years like
Coreper the corporate mentality it kind
of like with you a little wall of me up
and it was and as a guy Moxie was kind
of gone a little on the wackiness was
like subsided like someone put a big
chastity belt on my humor genitals
seriously so what so what did lead to
cutting the cord like a lot of negative
YouTube comments I got to get more a
system of me I've never heard no I think
it got to a point where I was like I am
unhappy at this corporate gross not
creative desk job even though it's super
comfortable the money's nice I'm able to
live comfortably you know I'm keeping my
wife happy everything's great life's
great but I'm not happy
and I wasn't what I really wanted to do
was to entertain people and so I just
took a massive chance and a massive pay
cut and was just like alright and I had
so many nights with Sarah willed can
this work can we can we do this can can
it like can we survive financially
financially and she was like this is
about as low as we can do and so I kept
going back and forth with the guys at
SourceFed I was like can we do this can
we do this can we do this and then
eventually they were like alright let's
do it and so I quit my job at Sony and I
started working at SourceFed and the
most intense anxiety I had ever felt in
my life
attacked my soul and mind and and
everything I had gone into like from the
wacky fun guy to like agoraphobic I
don't I can't leave my house type stuff
and this is when you were already host
yes this was like maybe a month or two
into barely starting as a full-time host
at SourceFed
and how did that manifest itself in any
way you're interacting with you know Joe
and for them they were very they were
very much confused because they were
like here's this like super
happy-go-lucky fun positive guy who as
soon as he's done shooting a video if he
could even get through a full video
without having like some sort of weird
panic attack or something suddenly is
not like
hanging out with us after work and
suddenly is not even talking to and like
and I would go like I remember the first
VidCon I ever went to I guess that was
2012 June of 2012 I think this was like
maybe like a month into the starting
SourceFed Joe was like dude I know
you're not gonna want to go to parties I
know you're not gonna want to talk to
people and stuff but like you are so new
in the YouTube world like you got to
talk to people and you got us seem like
a friendly person otherwise you're gonna
look like a dick to everybody it's like
here's this guy that just started on
SourceFed and now and he'd oh he won't
even talk to us and stuff like that but
little did they know and I tried telling
them I'm like dude I'm just something
happened I think it was a combination of
I got into this really crazy car wreck
in Culver City and I think was a
combination of that and cutting the cord
and your analogy of like the safety nets
gone from Sony to YouTube and suddenly
I'm like oh my god now there's like
thousands of people that are watching me
every day what was it was a car wreck
and how did that so the car wreck was
like I was driving home from work at
Sony one day and I just someone smashed
into me going like 80 miles per hour
destroyed my little VW Bug which I loved
so much I was fine I didn't like need to
go to the hospital or anything
I had a lot of back problems and all
that kind of stuff but I think it just
gave me this intense like PTSD like
after that I couldn't really Drive and I
already suffered and through anxiety my
entire life but I didn't know I didn't
know what it was I didn't know when you
feelings you talked about it was like a
resurgence of that weird hermit crab
zone that you described yes from you
know back of the end of your high school
exactly time and I went from a guy that
would like get up on stage and pull my
pants down and start singing and just to
being a guy that couldn't even leave the
house because of this like crazy
traumatic experience but you would leave
to shoot on SourceFed I would if you
couldn't make it through sometimes I
couldn't at all sometimes I would be
sometimes I would be driving to work I'd
be like okay my heart's racing and I
called James and be like dude I've been
puking all night I can't come in to work
and then I would go home and I'd lock
myself in my room I would go under the
covers and I'd be like I think I'm dying
I don't know what's happening in my body
my brain where's the guy that used to be
able to like
do anything I didn't let you get help I
mean yeah I ended up going to therapy
and therapy didn't work at all it was
like you got to get in this mind space
you gotta take breathing and like take a
moment to go outside on the grass and
like do little yoga and like it what it
just was not working like nothing was
working
and then I honestly can't tell you 100%
with 100% certain certainty what got me
out of it but I think with a little bit
of guidance from Joe because Joe Bereta
is like the greatest mentor anyone could
ever have the dude is just why is beyond
his years he was so supportive
once he once I finally like opened up to
him and was like okay this is what's
going on with me I can't keep it from
everybody this is what it is
I guess it's anxiety attacks you know I
just need to be open with you guys and
tell you what this is and Joe was just
like super supportive was like dude
don't worry I'll help you as much as I
can and I think he just ended up
becoming like this comfort that came
from my peers and then from Sarah and
then from just like slowly getting into
the success of SourceFed and then
learning that this wasn't going to be
just this one-time thing that was gonna
fall apart
I think the stability of it really
brought my right I'll stay back up so it
wasn't one thing or there wasn't one key
it was the support of people around you
and then and kind of just slowly got it
was it a snap out I don't know I mean I
can't I can't or a slow climb out of it
I guess I guess it was a slow climb
because it wasn't I can't remember like
one day being so bad and then the next
day being like hey that was weird
it really was like months later because
then I could confide in people like meg
Meg Turney who at the time who then
started on the channel like a couple of
months after me as well who was like I
suffer from anxiety too and then I was
talking to other people are like oh yeah
I have panic attack a me leave the house
sometimes and it was kind of like
seeking kind of like solace from people
that were also going through the same
things that really kind of like helped
me break out of it a little bit and it
was I guess it was transitional did this
manifest itself in your work did you
think so can you go back and look at
those videos I was oh yeah thank you
yeah yeah Sarah could even see it - she
used to watch videos and be like you
like you're sick you but you're like
gonna puke or something and I was like
yeah that's me having a straight-up
panic attack like that's a panic attack
both scream on screen on video yeah you
can go back to my early videos and
definitely see that I think and so
slowly or suddenly you can't really
figure out you kind of came out of that
yeah and you've kind of become the the
linchpin and in a lot of ways of
SourceFed as everyone yet you mentioned
that was there originally it's no longer
there yeah no longer there you've got
tenure I mean yeah yeah you're the only
one who could have that title at this
yeah it's true I'm the survivor but it I
mean I'm operating on the assumption
that you're not gonna be there forever
and that you're gonna be the next one to
depart from SourceFed even the tweet
from the SourceFed account on April
Fool's Day was that you were leaving so
what's the what's the plan what's the
approach I think for me it's one of
those things where I mean I've been
doing it for like three and a half years
now
I think that's three and a half years
right 2012 yeah sure yeah it's almost
three and a half years now so it's like
yeah and I think Phil even from the very
beginning was like when we had our like
kind of our interview meeting when we
kind of had lunch and just before I
started full-time at SourceFed Phil it
said to me you know if you guys are
still here in like five years if you
know then that I'm not doing my job
right I don't think the companies like
doing well because it's like this is
definitely kind of like a launching pad
for a lot of people I feel like and for
me I'm one of those guys that's like now
I'm a youtuber but I feel like it's
almost like it almost hurt it doesn't
feel good to say like I'm a youtuber
because there are people who like worked
their asses off from like getting zero
views on their videos to like to getting
very lucky and suddenly getting growing
this massive fan base I kind of just
jumped into a world that already had
this pre-existing fan base in Phil's
world and kind of you know three years
later built up a lot of stuff in
SourceFed and definitely was a big major
part of the success of SourceFed and
source
nerd but I feel kind of like ashamed to
be like yes I and I should be here along
the likes of joe bereta and luke barats
and rhettandlink and ol decay and people
like that who have put in like the work
you know so I feel kind of that kind of
stuff too but like I and I'll say the
but I think that having yeah I can see
that you know you might feel like you
you were a hired gun that then yes but
you should you helped shape something
that helped change the landscape of what
YouTube is arguably let's trim won a lot
of awards in the process you know so
it's that goes a long way I mean we all
get here in a lot of different ways yeah
it's true it's true I think I can say
much but you don't have as many
embarrassing videos when you are
emulating someone else before you
figured out what it is you were supposed
to do I have the videos that you needed
delete you were having a panic attack
sit with those but no I so yeah even
Phil was like if you're still working
there it's kind of bad but so for me
it's like so you're resigning I'm
resigning I'm quitting right now no I I
I don't see it I don't see myself just
gonna walk but when you do we know how
you're gonna do it you're gonna you're
gonna gather your stuff and you're just
gonna walk and not call anyone I mean
now that it's kind of like I've made
I've made full circle from the corporate
world of Sony into the corporate world
of discovery it's kind of like the
formalities need to stay kind of like on
the level there so I don't think I could
just run and go I can't Irish goodbye
that this or that job but at this point
especially if I don't want to burn any
bridges or anything like that but I mean
I I mean everyone's kind of looking for
the next thing right especially if
you're doing something long enough
you're like what's next you're always
thinking like what's next well I assume
that you you know you have a desire to
get out there and do your own thing yeah
and not and not even just like my own
thing like I kind of want to do you know
like maybe in the in the future like TV
and movies do you have a timeline I
don't I should but I don't I'm gonna be
33 in like a couple of weeks I'm an old
man and in YouTube years that's like
crazy right
we're like grandfathers where my eyes
are right I
but I mean like you know what I'm saying
like you got yours a Franks and you're
you can say we're close but so you've
experienced this transition you know it
sounds like some of those things have
been dealt with but you know you've also
been relatively open about what you've
gone through yes with your ex-wife yes
you've had a vlog in January yes it's
still up where you referenced another
vlog that is no longer no longer up
where you said I had a video that
explained a little bit about my personal
life but I took it down once I explained
what your mentality so I um yeah cuz
like man in this YouTube world it's very
much like nothing is personal nothing
can be kept secret in your in your
personal life or in your professional
life and so when things start going
south for Sara and I and like when it
started to become like you know she's
moving out of the house and like we're
actually splitting up it occurred to me
that like man I do vines and snapchats
and things like this where Sarah is like
in all of this stuff and Sarah was even
doing like little episodes of my my
shows on my personal channel with me
like we would review like the leftovers
or like Game of Thrones or something
like that so she's very much a part and
you know she would be in my like live
streams you could hear her talking about
things while she was like knitting
little characters and stuff mhm and so
when it got to the point where like
things gone had gone south in our
relationship and we weren't living
together anymore I was like okay fans
are gonna start to like wonder where the
hell Sarah is and they already were and
then they're gonna try to find things
out and then spread rumors and then the
next thing I know it's gonna be like all
this misinformation and Here I am
dealing with the ridiculousness of like
splitting up from someone and then the
potential for divorce and all this
insanity in my own personal life on top
of like how am I gonna explain this to
the viewers and how am I gonna explain
that I'm being like a total jerk or kind
of like you can see it on my face and
table talks that I'm like visually
visibly unhappy something's going on
like what's wrong with Steve he seems
angry or weird and obviously I've got
all this terrible stuff happening in my
personal life so there has to be some
sort of explanation and to me there had
to be some sort of like setting the
records
type thing but what do you I mean with
so much change from you know you met her
at a really difficult time yes she
helped pull you out of that yes you
continue to go through difficult time
you changed a lot personally was this a
well we fell in love in high school and
now we're different people like what is
your I think it was very much that it
was one of those things where it was
like so we we got married in 2006 we had
known each other at this point for like
12 years and then you know something
like that 12 years 11 years and then
married for like eight years and so it
was like we got to a point where we were
changing so much as as individuals and
because of my intense busyness in the
YouTube world and because of like I
started doing other work and I start
traveling abroad I would go to like
start traveling to different conventions
and I would be home less and less and it
started become one of those things where
was like my personal life was almost
non-existent with Sarah which was unfair
to her so just got to a point where it
was like I'm not being fair to her
because she wants something out of life
and she's not being fair to me because I
want something else out of life so is
this very mutual kind of like this is
what we need to do right and for me it's
like I'm am I gonna not take these
opportunities that could lead to
something bigger and better for us just
because like you know we need to be more
personally together and do that kind of
thing and so is we were both being
unfair to each other for what we wanted
in life so we just decided let's just
call it off
let's just do this let's just move on
how difficult was that heart I mean I'd
say the hardest thing I've ever had to
do in my life for sure I mean it was
very very difficult I mean obviously I
very much was in love with Sarah and we
were very much in love with each other
so was one of those things that was like
we were so young when we decided to get
married that it was like it was almost
like in a weird way it was like destined
for failure it was destined to be some
sort of like we would split ways and
grow apart and change so it was it was
very very difficult but I mean and even
more difficult to be like is this what I
want a life am I make
the right decision by ending a marriage
by mutually ending a marriage because
like this is what I want out of life but
I mean it's not it wasn't just that
obviously there were many other little
issues here and there like little
relationship issues mm-hmm but it
ultimately came down to this is this is
something I've always wanted to do with
my life and I need to pursue it and I
can't not go that way you know right see
I still talk we do we do we didn't there
was some very difficult times in the
beginning and some animosity and some
anger and but now we're supercool now
it's like I'm happier than I'm ever than
I have ever been in my life and so am i
and we're both saying these things to
each other like this is the best
decision we both could have made and I
think it's like the fact that she's
happy and like feels amazing and feels
better than she ever has is like perfect
for me it's I love that I want her to be
happy I want her to move on I want her
to to get everything she wants so like
now that she's kind of like on this road
to doing that I feel so happy for her
I feel absolutely happy for her are you
happy or are you just starting to be
able to get happier like it where are
you in that pro I'm happy I'm happy
because I because it's I'm no longer
wasting someone's time that I care a lot
about and and in the process I am
fulfilling the my personal needs as well
so I'm like in a really good place right
now
in your vlog you said 2015 was a year of
change you know almost six months into
that year yeah so what's changing I mean
I'm definitely not I'm like the like
married guy
I'm definitely now this like just this
kind of disconnected from that kind of
weird lifestyle guy so now I'm just kind
of like this free man that is just kind
of like not super concerned with with
this other person that I could
potentially be offending or not spending
enough time with or something like that
not to say that like all relationships
suck or marriage sucks or whatever but
it's like those responsibilities not
being such a massive
wait on me and the and those and the
ideas of the arguments and just kind of
like the endless frustration is being
gone makes me a completely different
person
it makes me happier it makes me I feel
like I concentrate more on my work I
feel like I'm I'm more focused on where
my career is heading it's I don't know I
feel like it's it's the best thing I
could have done for myself for my career
and for my emotions and how do you think
that change is gonna manifest itself in
your career I mean you we talked about
okay well a SourceFed isn't gonna last
forever is that does that change that
you're experiencing personally lead to
this desire for a professional change
yeah I mean I think it does and I think
it I think the fact that like I'm
putting out an album this year and
actually doing it is a big deal because
before it would be something I would
just talk about and be like oh I want to
do that and I'm gonna do it and then I
wouldn't because it would be like well
you know I've got this other life I'm
dealing with and you know I've got you
know my wife and I this and and I've got
all this other stuff going on I mean
these vlogs I mean now it's like not to
say that I have more time but I just
feel more focused on things that I
definitely want to and need to do with
my life and I feel like that's where
2015 is it's writing songs about whales
about whales animals yeah
exactly and what is the little with a
cute little thing what are the axolotl
axolotl which I will look up immediately
you got if you can even spell it I dare
you oh well I'm gonna be Wikipedia in
this thing right after this yeah
Wikipedia the hell out of work or
prettiness
that's even a word well listen man
thanks for uh being so candid with us in
your story it's cool to get to know you
yeah
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with steve zaragoza tweet at Steve his
handle is steve zaragoza GOC a hashtag
ear biscuits let him know what you
thought of the conversation and that's
always good so we really do appreciate
that and reviewing this show on itunes
and I have taken it upon myself to look
up the axolotl you googled it I did he
said you wouldn't know how to spell it
well I misspelled it at first and then
they asked me see who's right did you
mean this I mean how would you ever know
to say this a exo-l OTL axolotl yeah X a
lot Oh
oh I thought it was a XE elo ti axolotl
not X a logical ah T okay yeah that
would be an axolotl that it's a memory
yeah okay yeah is this worthy of a Steve
song I mean based on your thing is
ridiculous extinct interesting well it's
crazy so it's also known as the Mexican
salamander or the Mexican walking fish
the picture on Wikipedia is not this
picture right here when that's in
captivity is really really interesting
it's an underwater creature
it's a salamander and salamanders aren't
necessarily underwater their amphibious
aren't they it's yeah well I mean yeah I
guess amphibious I mean they need water
to survive they have to be close to
water but anyway it looks like a deep
sea creature the yeah but it's not as of
2010 wild axolotls were near extinction
due to urbanization in Mexico City and
consequent water pollution so they're
like living in the interior of the
country because no Mexico City is like
land bound landlocked or whatever so
this isn't this is a freshwater
salamander but a four month long search
in 2013 turned up no surviving
individuals in the wild so people are
like going out and trying to find these
things so there's still some in
captivity but they can't find any in the
wild at least in terms of it since 2013
so I guess it's just gone extinct man
it's kind of sad I guess so it is gonna
be a lullaby as this thing slowly fades
into non-existence
maybe his song will well you know have
an insurgents and bring them back I
don't think that's how it works I don't
think a song is gonna bring this thing
back link well if the song makes them
want to procreate then maybe it will
well it's not a la la lullaby but more
of a slow jam okay a slow jam for
axolotls we need to tell Steve that and
slow jam that Axl I'm never gonna bring
him back and let him loose in Mexico
City all right okay sounds like a plan
maybe maybe we should do that we could
be a part of that we should start a
foundation I don't know if we're
committed to that plan or the foundation
but we are committed to delivering
another ear biscuit the Association
souls the Association for the
establishment of a new axolotl
population via slow jams that's the name
of that you can figure out what that
spells and try to pronounce it on your
own time yeah here at you next week
[Music]
[Music]